Irán está lejos de ser el mismo país que
lo era hace seis meses por múltiples
motivos uno de ellos por este velo que
se han dejado caer muchísimas mujeres
incluso muchas de ellas se han quitado
después de que Max a mini esta joven de
22 años muriera después de haber sido
capturada por la policía de la moral el
huracán del centro de Teherán no muy
lejos de aquí por no llevar
supuestamente bien su velo a pesar de
que las autoridades han negado
atropellos en contra de esta jóvenes que
cuando estaba capturada sufrió una
muerte cerebral para muchas miles y
miles de jóvenes que han sido capturadas
durante estos años por esta policía y
han sido testigos de los atropellos para
ellas Esto no es un argumento Y acusan a
esta policía de haber sido la causante
de la muerte de esta joven y por eso de
allí esas protestas que sacudieron al
país inmediatamente después de su
fallecimiento y también porque la
mayoría de las mujeres la mayoría de
ellas muy jóvenes también Hicieron estas
protestas quitándose el velo lo que ha
cambiado no solamente al país sino
también a la actitud del régimen de la
república islámica que reprimió con el
enorme violencia esas protestas más de
500 personas fallecieron durante las
primeras semanas especialmente así lo
han monitoreado organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos que siguen la situación
en Irán miles y miles de personas muchos
de ellos jóvenes estudiantes terminaron
en prisión pero respecto al velo lo que
ha hecho la República islámica es tratar
de mirar hacia otro lado al menos cuando
las personas las personas no cantan
eslóganes políticos en la calle han
tratado de reponerlo de otra manera Por
ejemplo cerrando cafés y restaurantes o
monitoreando en las calles con cámaras
Pero esto es bastante difícil Esto hace
que este haya sido uno de los grandes
cambios en este año persa que terminará
el 21 de marzo
muchos también saben que en gran parte
de la población o un gran sector se
alejó del régimen muchas de ellas ya lo
estaba pero la manera como reprimieron
estas protestas hizo que mayor parte de
la población estuviera descontenta con
sus autoridades